THURSDAY MARCH ELEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER- PLEASE BE ADVISED AN
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEDURE IS BEING
MADE. AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
OF MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
SENATE FLOOR. GIPSON HERE
KAMLAGER LEAVE ME HERE LEVINE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS- RAMOS THE
APPROVED BY. NO KARM WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA MOVED BY MISTER
GIPSON SECULAR MEMBERS RAMOS OF
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA GIPSON
HI GIPSON HI KAMLAGER. LI LI HI
LEVINE. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS. MATHIS I RAMOS
RAMOS HI- IF YOU PUT WHAT. YOU
COULD WELL HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
HI. MOTION PASSES MOTIONS
PASSED AND- THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AMARA WAIT ARE SAID
HER FOR A MOMENT THANK YOU ALL
FOR JOINING. SENATOR.
THE
REASON RULES COMMITTEE IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED.